hello friends and welcome to my 500th
video i have my 80s hair in full force
for this actually baffled the people can
watch 500 on my videos and still not get
sick and tired of my voice and face so
thank you for that before you get your
hopes up I'm gonna let you know I really
didn't have anything planned for my
500th video I mean I would like to have
but I had planned on part one with a
full movie preview being on Monday in
today's Monday and it happens to be the
500 video so what to do I don't know but
I would like to think that a sincere
thank you is all you require of me so
thank you for getting me to 500 videos
and 140 something thousand subscribers
that's absurdly awesome like I always
say there is more to come plus a meteor
hits the earth it ends all life I will
keep cranking out content for you guys
but I'm now going to give you what's
become sort of a tradition which is the
full movie preview and it breaks down
like this I go down to California hang
out with the schmoes from schmoes know
we have a good time and we film the fall
movie preview for part preview part 1 is
September that's on my channel October's
on there's November's on mine December's
on there so we're just going to jump
right into this which is the revelation
that we actually cheat and use in
Entertainment Weekly magazine because
we're that's how we roll enjoy who's got
the magazine show magazine very good
sheet every year we get Entertainment
Weekly that's what we do we don't
memorize can we see [ __ ] in your channel
you should [ __ ] organic [ __ ] September 7
you got a whole bunch of stuff coming
out starting with Bachelorette starring
kirsten dunst how do we all feel about
this light amazed but not bridesmaids
it's the gobots of bridesmaids that's
one of it yeah that's right at Bryce
base was really really funny made a lot
of money some batteries suitors gonna be
like hey let's get more girls together
in a wedding kind of thing exactly what
it's like you know when they did the
matrix everybody in every movie was more
like this yeah now now every girl comedy
is going to be this you know saving
grace all like a funny bizarre kind of
[ __ ] so if your girl comic your time is
now right
thank you you gonna wear my pajamas like
a Michael Jackson posing out September
seventh we have the words with Bradley
Cooper and jeremy irons and it's bradley
cooper who was this writer he finds a
manuscript and he goes and he and he
submits it becames really famous of it
and then Jeremy Irons comes back and
says hey you [ __ ] that's mine okay
you don't have to just drop f-bombs
laughing like a journal he's not [ __ ]
around I'm not I have to tell you
something wait not over yet this is
where it really
that's interesting it's kind of the same
thing like what you're saying is that
it's like limitless right he's a writer
who steal who illegally gets powers and
now he's got to deal with it luckily
it's the lay in bed with zoe saldana so
it can't be that bad limit list with no
pills for a drug-free America Thank You
the steel man's life expect to be no
price to pay
so 10 or 14th you have this thing coming
out called arbitrage with Richard Gere
where he is going to essentially be
playing Bernie Madoff where he's a
billionaire he's caught up in the
scandal he's embezzling stuff and he
gets caught up apparently it's like the
Oscar push for Richard Gere but it's not
officially Bernie Madoff no no this is
another story you know what's great is
it I want to see a rich off a rich guy
off between Michael Douglas and Richard
Gere there maybe the two best guys
Everett plane does rich dudes I want to
see him jowls on Broadway they get
youngish chicks half of the funds assets
are missing there's a 400 million dollar
home here that's ridiculous you're
looking at a thousand years jail time
what am I supposed to do you know
Richard of year has never been nominated
for an awesome yeah yeah you'd be amazed
at how many people you thought got
nominated for Oscars never been
nominated for an Oscar my heart when I
cried watching nights in rodanthe on to
the next movie yeah this movie know
you're very excited about this the perks
of being a wallflower this is what fun
looks like welcome to the island of
misfit toys hermione drops the English
accent becomes their American and and
who knows based off a novel she's a
teenager she rebellious but we'll see
what the hell i love that vague
description direction i'm remaining in
america and I guess but isn't that the
thing is that really like cuz you're
like you see jority the audience that's
watching they're gonna go who's in it
Hermione does she show her ass maybe why
do I and everyone I love pick people who
treat us like we're nothing we accept
the love we think we deserve
hey yet you made fun of my destroy had
to listen to you freeze man back when I
said she was hot when the second harry
potter movie came out i got nothing but
crap for now so she's gorgeous edgren
side of the curve this guy I'm frog
masticate in this moment I swear we are
infinite all right and then who cares
about this thing Resident Evil part 75
my name is Alice no Alice how nice to
see you again what the hell is going on
here we have you under all control
there's another one yes I've never been
a fan of the resident evil movies i love
the Resident Evil games resident evil
force at the pinnacle of Resident Evil
games you've got to play to check it out
but the resident evil movies nah i gross
oh yeah well your site about how they
still do the matrix stuff today that
movie they still do matrix stuff except
with the you know undead people right
look I'm sure it'll be fun to watch that
stuff blow up in three de milla jovovich
is hot so
if you actually ran the movie in real
time kinda novice limo you'll have a
25-minute Peter I don't understand how
they make the a triple releases anymore
you think those things will go straight
to DVD alright September 21st now and we
have something called ten years with
Channing Tatum man any sucker I got fed
what did you eat with your kids Channing
Tatum was like a real movie star now
that guys actually like him Yeah right
yeah he's not just like the [ __ ] who
takes off shirt looks pretty for about
30 minutes in the movie he's actually
says 21 Jump Street on me I'm like oh
well he's cool hey Jake I think you owe
me a dance
you've never told me why you guys broke
up I stayed as long as I could I just
needed to grow up so do you guard up now
I like them in a male stripper movie I
guess yeah right guess they were sitting
so close together never not on my town
all right now we have a thing that I am
I don't know how to feel about this i
know some people are excited dredd 3d
800 million people living in the ruin of
the old world this movie looks like they
had a movie they had a concept about
someone who needed to implement a
building and someone pitched it to the
studio and they were like all right hold
on now how about we put Judge Dredd miss
living it's not necessary but I think it
should happen I want him dead we're
gonna have to go through and broking you
ready yeah yo creddie yeah parent Lee
Karl Urban was like a huge fan of the
comics but it seems like everybody
that's gets cast and comic movies now
was a huge run of the comic so I I don't
know it just it looks like it's going to
be overly violent but sometimes there's
going to be more of that style and
substance and it might lose me it can be
fun but I'm trust a movie like that
that's coming out in September and also
that's got a lot of competition that
weekend because I believe that next we
were talking about is that Clint
Eastwood pieces i'm looking forward to
sentence is death
yes is trouble with the curve where he
cleans wit plays an aging scout need
anything hoodies with voice I was gonna
be aging shopping Amy I'm his daughter
and then I quit plays an aging old guy
hahaha does he own no I guess that means
I can come in damn it some new kind of
style are not up on ice fang shmaya
don't you know anything oh that's what
he sounds like to me every time here at
least with talk I heard back me a damn
check trust me I can handle it you need
to meet with a specialist how are you
gonna scalp this guy if you're I zone
right but this one he's an aging scale
and Timberlake is his like competitor
and you know the Timberlake's don't want
to fall in for Amy Adams and then it's
gonna do well I guess you can date my
daughter get off my lawn could be Oscar
his first time in what 20 years at
Eastwood is is gonna move that he's not
directed still single I sure maybe you
are emotionally unavailable who are you
dr. Phil hey that is quality television
yeah closing out the September 21st is
housed at the end of the street with
Katniss herself Jennifer Lawrence in
this horror trailer I like Lawrence than
she's a great actress this movie doesn't
look fantastic I think Jennifer
Lawrence's I mean she's nominated for an
Oscar she's cat and she's coming into
her own I feel like this movie's a step
back
there's a horror movie I get excited
about these and also it's not just
aren't Jennifer Lawrence's also has Miss
Elizabeth Shue Chris Parker from
adventures and days that's not a selling
point they were right I know my just
havin it could have been dude all
deliveries I did is because I thought
her mind he was obvious used to Young's
and I'm going older with all his shoes
so now the average makes me not creepy I
feel like this is what happened she
booked this movie before she became as
big as she was now that she is she's
like long as I contractually happy to do
it all right then September 28th you
close out September you have a couple
more things coming out you have Hotel
Transylvania with the voices of Adam
Sandler and a nice amber coming off
their last piece that's all I was funny
I laugh a lot of that's my boring hotel
transylvania i saw a terrible for it it
looks like a really really funny
animated movie human free since 1898
hello a human adam sandler his movie
says of light they're not as they were
they're not as good as they were as of
old maybe animations are saying a nice
amber the last couple movies that he's
done he hasn't been utilized he's so
goofy and gentlemen and he was in the
celeste and jesse and he wasn't goofy in
that he was and that's my boy that was
in goofy so hopefully he's able to bring
that side out in animation doing boy saw
somebody loves goofy take him to
Disneyland that's just that's what the
guys got here what is wrong with you
people something yeah so the big wine in
September is that is also coming out the
last week in September and that's looper
don't know this already it's me I don't
want to talk about time travel we both
know how this has to go down so why
don't you do their old man two and guy
which is the one I'm very excited about
and it's joseph gordon-levitt as young
Bruce Willis looking like young bruce
willis and bruce willis where he goes
back to try to kill himself yeah but as
you said it could be all sweet bruce
willis are all over his horses the only
rule is never let your target escape
even if you target miss you Emily Blunt
is also in this film she played in and
she's she's one of those up-and-coming
actresses that is so far and it's the
director of brick who wanted to work
with Joseph gordon-levitt again I really
think that this thing's getting a lot of
buzz I think this is going to be one of
the most memorable sci-fi pieces in a
while [ __ ] one mission I make a
prediction and I'm telling you this is
gonna be a memorable film
you remember last fall when yeah yeah
honestly the Immortals gonna do the
greatest film I ever seen in my tears I
guys have you seen the fall have you
seen the tall Falls a good move I think
the cash is great Joseph gordon-levitt I
love Bruce Willis I'm by everyone loves
blissfully Emily Blunt ever since
especially the adjustment bureau yeah I
was like that's the girl right there the
premise is great but I hope it's not one
of those ones like I mean you remember
in time to you remember immortals it's
one of those ones where it could be a
movie where you're excited about that
you see you're like well that did come
out in September all right maniacs
that's what we have 4 sep tember don't
worry we have three more months to come
we have october november december the
next month is going to be on their
channel go check them out go subscribe
to them because if you don't it's going
to be September November and there's
more to fold you're gonna lose months
yeah you don't want to lose months you
don't want to lose time go check these
maniacs out go subscribe to them and as
always if you like what you've seen here
you want to see more click right here to
seem alarm that camera is really far
away I'm do it I guess